only have 12 bullets so you're gonna
have to share
is the mask watching my voice
ladies and gentlemen what your witnesses
i've never said this but don't swallow
incoming
i promise this gets worse for you big
boy
[Music]
that doesn't how's it going everybody
it's warren welcome back to my channel
the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and today we've got
something pretty cool to talk about
and that is the deadpool animated series
now what you just saw was
test footage for what would have been
donald glover's childish gambino's
deadpool animated series
now some people might not have known
this but donald glover was planning on
producing and starring in
this deadpool animated series and this
was going to be based off of a little
bit what we got from the actual deadpool
films planning on building off of the
hype of the previous films to bring this
animated series to life and to give us
something new
because as you can see even though it
was ryan reynolds voice
dubbed over they did plan on it being
pretty similar to the deadpool films it
was going to be rated r it was going to
be pretty raunchy
and you know it was going to be pretty
hilarious it was pretty much just like
the deadpool films but just animated so
a while ago donald glover posted on
twitter
a picture of the script for this
deadpool animated series he was really
excited to go forward and marvel was as
well
now unfortunately later on the tweet
would go on to be deleted and
unfortunately the show
would go on to be scrapped they
cancelled it which was a huge bummer for
everybody who knew what was going on
with the series
especially if you consider the fact that
they really didn't give us a reason for
why they canceled the series they had
already been well underway with it as
you can see here we have the test
footage that they actually made
and then they cancelled it out of
nowhere without really giving us a
reason
but sadly we pretty much know what
happened see this was a project
originally under fox this happened
before the disney fox deal when fox
still owned the rights to
deadpool but then of course the deal
went through and disney acquired the
rides to deadpool and once they got the
rides to deadpool they apparently
scrapped the project because it was too
racy it was too raunchy it was too
racist
and just didn't really fit with disney
so-called brand
but it is deadpool that's who deadpool
is that's what he does
those are the type of jokes that he
makes he's not afraid to make all of the
jokes and that's actually why a lot of
people really love him that and he
breaks the fourth wall of course
and unfortunately right now we live in a
world where some people get upset over
sensitive jokes
and right now it's very apparent that
disney is really trying to be socially
acceptable
so this was a project that just kind of
really didn't fly for them
and they would ultimately end up
canceling what would have been an
awesome deadpool animated show produced
by donald glover
now after hearing this a lot of you may
be asking well what about the
live-action deadpool films with ryan
reynolds
well we know for a fact that ryan
reynolds has met with marvel studios
he's actually posted pictures of him at
marvel studios online on his instagram
and twitter
and in a few interviews he actually said
that he's working on deadpool 3
over at marvel studios now and of course
not too long ago maybe a month or two we
got the report that ryan reynolds right
now was in the process of signing the
biggest
marvel studios deal ever bigger than
robert downey jr's which would mean he
would have to sign the deal for about
nine
movies so deadpool is clearly sticking
around he's going to be in the mcu
however which version of deadpool that
we're going to get is a little bit
unclear right now
is he going to be pg-13 is he going to
be rated r or is he going to be rated r
but tone down just a little bit to not
make certain jokes
deadpool 1 and 2 were extremely
successful films and if disney is smart
which
typically they kind of are and they
listen to kevin feige head of marvel
studios
they won't mess with a great thing now
there have been rumors and i stress that
these are only rumors at this point
nothing is confirmed that disney could
possibly do another division that's
going to do
all of their rated r films but it would
be sort of an
off branded disney label it would be
under disney and
marvel but it would be called something
else so people don't associate
rated r raunchy things with the disney
name now that's just a rumor for now and
if disney doesn't want to get their
hands dirty that's a route that they can
go for sure
we'll have to wait and see on that and
there's one thing that is certain and
that is that this show would have been
hilarious it's unfortunate that we never
got it maybe perhaps they'll try to pick
it up again in the future
but until then this is all we get this
test footage of something that could
have been
truly awesome but let me know would you
have liked to have seen this deadpool
animated series be sure to let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
and don't forget to subscribe to stay up
to date on all things marvel and so you
can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a tony stark funko pop
provided by heroes hideout.com
if you're looking for funko pops and
marvel figures of all kind you can check
them out at heroeshideout.com don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof